the joker has been portrayed in many
movies over the years
as time marches on more cinematic takes
on the joker are created
and new rules for the characters silver
screen portrayals are established
but despite these different
interpretations these are the rules
batman's nemesis has to follow in every
film
the joker is known for many things
dating a psychiatrist killing robin
and even attempting to copyright fish
yet there's still one thing that makes a
joker really stand out on the grim
streets of gotham his luck
the criminal mastermind is known by fans
for wearing purple with green hair
a color combo that appears at least once
in each film portrayal
some batman villains are also recognized
for their wild style
like the riddler the mad hatter and
polka dot man but as the years have gone
on gotham's bad guys have come to favor
monochromatic tactical armor
and subdued gangster suits in keeping
with the noir aesthetic established in
the early comics
by contrast the joker bursts off the
page and onto the screen in colours
rarely worn by villains
especially in movies when the joker is
on screen with batman the audience's
eyes are inevitably drawn to the circusy
tableau
that is the joker's hair suits and
garish makeup
to do the legendary villain justice a
film portrayal of the joker requires a
get
up so loud it takes away attention from
the guy the movie's named after
the joker's sense of humor not only
gives the character his name but also
defines his crimes
the joker may have failed as a stand-up
comedian but he still builds entire evil
plots around punchlines
puns and one-liners sure he might be
looking to kill you but the joker is
also
definitely out to make you laugh each
new joker actor is tasked with finding
their unique take on the joker's
particular sense of humor
heath ledger's portrayal in 2008's the
dark knight is a sterling example of an
actor blending up horror behavior and
comedic timing to draw some genuine if
regretful laughs from the audience
whether it's the dry delivery of a quip
after he brains a criminal with a pencil
i'm gonna make this pencil disappear
or the dark physical comedy ledger
brings to the joker's frustration with
the detonator
the beloved actor set the bar as twisted
comedic beats like these that give the
character his staying power
when he's on screen no one knows whether
to be ready for something hilarious
something horrific
or the joker's own blended brand of both
any worthwhile villain needs a theme
song
vader has the imperial march the shark
in jaws has john williams themed from
jaws
and characters in any martin scorsese
movie have the rolling stones
these songs alert the audience that the
villain has arrived with the special
exception of jack nicholson's art to
facing dance party in 1989's batman
said to the tune of princess party man
the joker's theme isn't a song
it's his devilish cackle
[Music]
the laugh which hits an octave that
immediately registers as maniacal is so
iconic that the new york times published
an entire feature on the pressure actors
feel to get it right on screen
most of the performers who have played
the part over the years credit one man
with mastering the joker laugh
mark hamill who voiced joker in batman
the animated series
as hamill revealed to the times his
audition script brought an explicit
command
don't think nicholson so he drew
inspiration from amadeus the blue
meanies from 1968's yellow submarine
and dwight fry's 1930s dracula movies
hamill's performance may only be vocal
but he set the benchmark for what
audiences think a joker laughs should be
[Laughter]
the 80s was a formative decade for the
joker and batman
frank miller's the dark knight returns
and batman the killing joke by alan
moore and brian barland
gave the caped crusader a new and gritty
edge that would come to define his
corner of the dc
universe miller's work focuses on the
dark long-term relationship
forms between the two men literally
having them fight to the death
in a tunnel of love ride [ __ ] barlin's
tale explores the insanity these
characters share
where batman stares and blinkingly into
chaos the joker has flung himself
straight in these depictions didn't just
give audiences an interesting new
conflict
they also turned joker into a night
perfect batman villain
who is the hero's opposite in nearly
every sense this dynamic has vividly
colored how movies portray the
relationship between these foes
no matter who plays him the joker will
do anything to sow chaos
and batman will do almost everything to
stop him even in 2019's joker
arthur fleck has a conflicted connection
with young bruce wayne while the villain
acting as the hero's dark mirror is a
well-worn trope
it's rarely done so perfectly audiences
are always entertained when his ledger
says in the dark knight
an unstoppable force meets
an immovable object while the joker
might not be able to bring himself to
kill the man behind the cow
he'll certainly knock off the people
closest to the caped crusader
even when he's not targeting batman it's
the wayne family he's after
such as the grudgy halt against them in
2019's joker
ever since comic fans voted for the
joker to kill jason todd in 1988
movie adaptations have heavily leaned
into the personal toll he exacts upon
his foe
in 1989's batman the joker is a man who
murders wayne's parents
in 1993's batman mask of the phantasm
the joker almost kills the love of
batman's life
in 2000's batman beyond return of the
joker it's revealed that he kidnapped
tim drake
comics third robin and brainwashed him
as a child to grow up to be the next
joker
most famously in 2008's the dark knight
the joker kidnaps batman's childhood
friend and old flame
blows her up and in the process makes
harvey dent into two-face
at this point in the filmography joker
is the grand marshal of batman's tragedy
parade
the movie franchise has explored many
tones from camp to thriller noir to pure
action
the characters need something to ground
them through these many fluctuations
something audiences can immediately
grasp the joker threatening batman with
the loss of loved ones is intimately
recognizable to anyone no
matter who's in the director's chair
many great actors have portrayed bruce
wayne over the years but no matter how
talented the performer in the batsuit
might be
whenever batman and the joker share the
screen the actor playing the joker
upstages his pointy-eared counterparts
take 1989's batman jack nicholson's
manic charisma fuels an iconic
performance
that draws attention from michael
keaton's reserved bruce wayne
when news broke that heath ledger would
be cast in the role for the dark knight
angry fans to cried the decision but
later changed their tune
upon the film's release legendary movie
critic roger ebert described legend's
joker as
the key performance in the movie he
followed that sentence by predicting
leger's posthumous oscar win
the potential for prestigious actors to
run away with the role
has become so entrenched in the
zeitgeist that todd phillips built his
entire standalone joker film around
joaquin phoenix's
bizarre difficult and ultimately
oscar-winning performance
unlike some beloved characters the joke
is aesthetic and attitude adjusts the
current moment
by contrast batman may receive some suit
upgrades but he retains roughly the same
tabulation of grimaces
batarangs and tactical leather the joker
evolves while batman stands still
jack nicholson's joker dances to prince
and his gangs coordinated berets
ray-bans and parachute pants give their
enterprise a distinctly late 80s sense
of chic
in batman mask of the phantasm hamel's
joker wears a sleek purple suit and a
dangerously toothy grin
in keeping with the retro noir aesthetic
of the 90s cartoon
something interesting happened in 2008
heath ledger's joker is notably grimy
looking
and also adopts a criminal attitude that
reflects the era's post on 11 fear of
terrorism
recently the joker's portrayals have
shifted for a generation that grew up
with the internet
jared leto's joker and suicide squad is
a patreon page away from being a
criminal influencer
while joaquin phoenix's joker taps into
societal fear of the sort of lonely
disenfranchised men
who have become closely associated with
the darkest corners of the internet
parts of the joker's appeal is his
status as the ultimate wild card he is
likely to betray anyone and anything at
a moment's notice
from comic appearances to the small
screen to the silver screen portrayals
of the joker excel when he's acting
unpredictably
his status as a villain allows writers
the freedom to have him make choices the
hero never would
while his reputation as a maniac keeps
everyone even his alleged allies on
their toes
when he's not throwing his own henchmen
into harm's way for self-preservation
he's setting two-face loose on the same
men who paid the joker to kill batman
or if he's keeping it simple he's
burning mountains of cash in an
interview with the bbc
director christopher nolan explained how
the joker's sporadic behavior
was baked into every aspect of ledger's
performance but a lot of it was about
unpredictability and i think he wanted
to
play his cards a little closer to the
chest that sort of mystique makes a
villain instantly fascinating and
endlessly watchable even if done through
eye shielding fingers
any cinematic portrayal of the joker
worth at salt features a grand entrance
these arrivals aren't just cool they
also announce the joker's presence in a
grandiose way
that immediately raises the narrative
stakes for example ledger's entrance in
the dark knight
is a tightly constructed double cross by
the time the final bank robber realizes
that the joker has instructed all the
men on the job to execute each other the
audience has a clear idea of the type of
joker they're dealing with
leger's joker is a madman yes but the
opening robbery also demonstrates as
ruthless intelligence
and calculated plotting in joker where
keen phoenix's complete take on the
character doesn't arrive until the third
act
when he does finally appear in full
regalia his entrance isn't punctuated
with a fight scene or a heinous
crime instead it's a dance number
phoenix's joker debut said to gary
glitter's rock and roll part 2
couldn't be more different from leger's
reveal however both entrances set new
standards for grand joker arrivals
humor alone does not a good joker make
he should also be terrifying
while the joker is an inherently
vivacious and charismatic villain
his staying power comes from the way he
blends that charisma with horror
consider the hostage tapes the film the
joker sends gotham news stations
in the first act of the dark knight with
its homemade style purposefully
amateurish editing and its unmixed audio
the terrifying tape appears to have
rolled in from another movie
it's deeply disturbing later when
legends joker holds a dinner party
hostage on the hunt for harvey dent
everyone on screen and in the theater
feels their palm sweat as they become
aware of the joker's intentions for his
victim
it's moments like these that are
essential to the character's power over
moviegoers plenty of villains have flair
many crack jokes
and most of an army of dispensable goons
who rarely receive first and last names
but the joker is one of those special
villains whose back is worse than his
formidable bite
a joker's ability to evoke a visceral
response from the audience whenever he's
on screen
is what has ingrained the character in
the public consciousness fans of every
age remember childhood hair standing up
on the backs of their necks when they
hear his sinister laugh
there's one fundamental rule movie
portrayals of the joker must follow that
trumps all the others
the joker can never kill batman one of
the most interesting things about the
joker is his desire to keep his arch
nemesis alive
he even admits as much in the dark
knights interrogation scene saying
i don't want to kill you what would i do
without you
for most villains this approach would
really deflate the danger they present
to the hero
in contrast the joker's desire to
continue the fight makes him seem even
more dangerous
the never-ending struggle between batman
and the joker has become part of the
franchise's appeal
the joker often remarks that life
without batman would be boring
and the audience can't tell but feel the
same way he is constantly finding ways
to almost break the bat
and thus constantly finding new ways to
keep audiences interested
this homicidal well they won't they
dynamic makes a relationship
truly one of a kind and fans everywhere
are grateful for
it check out one of our newest videos
right here plus
even more looper videos about batman are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you